The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So finally,
it's our last recitation.
And finally, it's my favorite
topic-- cryptography--
because I work in this area.
So I have probably
a little bit more
than what's required
to tell you.
So this recitation is
access more primitives,
so we'll introduce several
more primitives that
may be useful to your
future work or study.
And so the first one
is digital signature.
So we have briefly
mentioned digital signatures
in the lecture, but mainly
as an application of Hatch,
so now I'm going to introduce
it as a standalone primitive.
So as you may have
already known,
digital signature is used for
verifying message authenticity.
And it's a pair of
function sign and verify.
So sign takes a secret
key and the message.
It outputs a signature,
which we refer to as sigma.
And verify takes a public key,
a message, and a signature,
and outputs on
either true or false.
It either accepts the
signature or reject.
So we use secret key to sign
and public key to verify.
That means so if I want
to send the message,
I should be the only one
who was able to sign it.
And everyone can verify
that this message indeed
comes from me.
So what properties do we
want from digital signatures?
Any thoughts on that?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
given the signature
in a message [INAUDIBLE]
to get the secret key.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
definitely one.
I'll put a more
general description
of what you just said.
Any other answers?
AUDIENCE: And only one
signature [INAUDIBLE],
like on any message coming out,
can you have one signature?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Hugo.
PROFESSOR: Hugo says a message
should only have one signature.
Let's think about
whether that's necessary.
So if my algorithm
is a randomized one
that for the same
message I output
many possible signatures.
So why is that bad?
So for any of
them, they will all
verify if that's how
my algorithm works.
I think that's fine.
That's OK.
It's not a bad thing.
Actually, randomized signature
is considered more secure.
They are less efficient.
Any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Do you care
about speed at all,
like how long it takes
to sign and verify?
PROFESSOR: That's
definitely one,
but we haven't got
any scheme yet,
so we care about
functionality first.
There are faster
signatures and slower ones.
So the first one is
actually very trivial.
We first want correctness.
What does that mean?
That means if this
sigma is indeed
generated by the
sign function that
verified that the output 1.
Otherwise, they
should put output 0.
That's actually the first
and the most basic property
we want.
I don't want to write it
because it's-- so the other one.
So your answer is very
close that you don't
want to extract the secret key.
But to make it more
general, what we really want
is unforgeability.
That means if I have the
secret key and someone
else-- an adversary, who does
not have the secret key--
should not be able to sign the
message to pretend to be me.
So they should not be able to
produce m star sigma star, such
that it verifies.
Make sense?
So what you said is a
special case of this.
So if they can extract, somehow
extract the secret key, then,
of course they can
forge my signature
on any other messages.
But we do want to also prevent
attack where they cannot
extract the secret key, but
they somehow can forge another
signature.
But usually we want to
make the adversary more
powerful because then we
have higher confidence
that we won't be attacked.
So adversary is totally
reasonable for it
to see a bunch of
messages from me.
Because I am signing messages
and output it to the world.
So an adversary may have seen
some of the message, signature
pairs, I generated.
But still we do not want
to create a forgery.
Now how is that defined?
Because see you can definitely
send one of these back.
That's a valid message
signature pair.
So our unforgeability
requirement
is defined to be--
he should not be
able to send such a
pair where m star is
different from any message
he has already seen.
There is no way to
prevent the adversary
from sending one of
the message signature
pairs he has seen before.
So far, pretty straightforward.
Now, how can we get
digital signatures?
So in the early days,
researchers-- and it's
actually great
computer scientists--
they proposed a
digital signature can
be implemented as the inverse
of public key encryption.
What does that mean?
So I'll use RSA as the example.
So RSA encryption
is m to the e mod n.
The encryption is
c to the d mod n.
So the first attempt
is we will just
use this as our sign
function and use
this as our verify function.
So now the symbol is a
little bit confusing.
So now I'm signing a
message [INAUDIBLE] c.
Let me actually change it.
This is RSA encryption.
I'm going to transform
it into signature scheme
where sign signs a message,
and verify, raise the signature
sigma to the power of e,
and checks whether or not
I get back my message.
So this actually
makes a lot of sense.
Why?
Because think of
m as a ciphertext.
Then if I decrypt it,
and then re-encrypt it,
I should get back my ciphertext.
So correctness-- we
have correctness.
And why is it unforgeable?
Because an attacker does
not have the secret key,
so he should not be able
to decrypt this m here.
He cannot run this algorithm.
That's the reasoning behind it.
So far so good?
But, unfortunately,
it is broken.
And so I'll give you, say,
seven minutes to think about it.
Can you come up with
an attack, a forgery?
You can see a bunch of messages
and then output a forgery
for a message you
haven't seen before.
So is the algorithm clear?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Can you speak louder?
AUDIENCE: Is it just the
product of any messages?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So if an adversary had
seen a bunch of messages--
because RSA has this sometimes
good, sometimes nice, sometimes
bad property, that is
multiplicative, homomorphic,
or to use a less fancy
word-- malleable.
So if they, an adversary,
sees this message,
it can set m star
to be m1 times m2
and sigma star to
sigma 1 times sigma 2.
You can check.
This is a valid signature,
message signature pair.
You take this entire
thing raised to d.
They are raised to d
individually and then
multiply together, and that's
exactly this message here.
Attack one.
OK.
There's actually another attack.
That's even simpler and
tells you this scheme
is even more broken.
So all I want to do is
to come up with a sigma
when it's raised to
e, that's equal to m.
So I'm going to
select the sigma,
compute, m sigma
raised to e, because e
is my public key, mod m.
I can do that.
And then output sigma
m-- oh sorry, m sigma.
I select the signature
first, and I raise it
to the power of e.
I get a very strange message,
but it doesn't matter.
That's my forgery.
OK, so now you can see
this scheme is basically
totally broken.
But they actually
come from our, well,
several renown scientists.
But why is that a case?
Because actually that
definition didn't
exist when they were
trying to when they
were working on this problem.
And so that definition
looks obvious today,
but it's actually
not obvious at all.
And I think this algorithm
came in the 70s, '78.
And in '82,
Goldwasser and Micali,
two professors from MIT,
proposed the definition
for signature encryption
and basically everything
in cryptography.
And they won another
Turing Award for that.
OK, so let's try to fix it.
Any ideas?
We do not want to
change the framework.
Let's still use RSA and combine
it with some other primitive
you have seen to try to fix it.
What do we want to do?
We want to break this
multiplicative property.
And we want to break this, this
step, whatever it's called.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can we
change the n, maybe?
PROFESSOR: Change this n?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right now,
just to remind you,
it's a product of
two primes, OK, pq.
It's a product of two primes.
It's how RSA works.
What's your idea?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Before it
raised to the power,
we can get the hash
function of it.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Let's just make a small change.
So sign will be hash
of m, raised to d.
And verify will be-- just
check whether hash of m
equals signature is to e.
This indeed fixes these attacks.
Why?
Because now you need-- well,
if you do this-- hash of m
and 1 times hash of m2 is not
going to be hash of m star
because hash is supposed
to be [INAUDIBLE] random.
That's not going to work.
And here, what
the attacker needs
to do is to find hash of m, such
that it's sigma raised to e.
It can still do
this, but it does not
know what this message is
because of the one-wayness
of hash function.
If we use a good
hash function there,
then it indeed fixes
both the attacks.
But we have seen the lecture
that this hash function also
needs to be collision resistant.
Remember that?
A question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
the message public?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
message-- oh, OK.
Good point.
Oh, no, but, OK, you are talking
about this attack, right?
So the attacker needs to
find the public message,
but all he can do is select
the sigma, and raise it to e.
That's going to
be its hash of m.
And then he cannot figure
out where this m is.
But what about the other way?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if
he has two messages,
he can still get m star,
and then get hash of m star.
PROFESSOR: OK, so he
then he gets, has of m1.
He gets hash of m2.
But you need to find the
m star, such that its hash
is the multiplication
of these two.
And, yeah, he does not know
how to find that message.
So if the hash is not
multiplicative, one-way,
and collision
resistant, then it seems
that we have fixed all
the attacks we know.
However, how do we know
there are no other attacks?
So actually, indeed,
this is a good idea.
We have several
national standards
that just use this but
slightly differently.
I can-- this is just
for your information.
So there's a standard called
[? NC, ?] whatever-- X93.1.
It uses RSA, this
word padding, so it
takes the hash of the message
and pad with this hex stream,
and prepended and append
another hex stream.
Why do they do that?
They don't know
either, but they just
think it's probably more
secure than only using a hash.
There's another
standard that has
a different steam and a
difference stream here,
and it doesn't matter.
So that's indeed a weakness
of these types of approaches.
So their security is
what we call ad hoc.
We do not know
how to break them.
But we do not know how to
prove they are secure either.
Yet, that's what
people do in practice.
So, unfortunately, that's
all I can tell you today,
so how not to construct
the digital signature.
I cannot tell you how to
construct the secure digital
signature because that's out
of the scope of this class.
And it's a major
topic in cryptography.
Any questions so far?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The hash function
here is the one way, yeah?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's one-way,
collision resistance, and--
AUDIENCE: So what is the
use of using the RSA?
Couldn't we just use the
only hash function then?
PROFESSOR: OK, good question.
So, OK, let's be clear
what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: OK, never mind.
PROFESSOR: Can you
answer your own question?
AUDIENCE: So my
question was, well,
why do we have to use the RSA?
Why, when we have
the hatch function?
You want me-- so [INAUDIBLE]
couldn't create the forgery.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How does
it create a forgery?
Just answer your own question.
Let everyone else know.
Maybe they have
the same question.
So answer your own question.
AUDIENCE: So my answer is
so adversary can't just
choose random message and
hash it and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What's the problem?
Problem is that a hash
function is a public function
that everybody can compute.
So the attacker just chooses
a message, compute as hash,
so using a hash is
not a signature.
But good point.
I'm actually coming to that.
So far we have seen three
major primitives-- private key
encryption, public
key encryption,
and digital signature.
So if we categorize
them a little bit--
so these two are asymmetric key.
They are public
key and secret key.
This one is symmetric key.
And these two are for secrecy.
They are trying to
hide the message.
And this one is for integrity.
Meaning, the message is
what the sender sends.
So you can see we are
missing one primitive here.
What if the two
parties, they do share
a secret key, and
one party wants
to verify the other party?
The other message indeed does
come from the other party.
So indeed we do have
a primitive for that.
It's called message
authentication code.
So its definition is
basically exactly the same
as digital signature.
I'm just going to
change it here.
Except that it has only one key.
So the sign function
is replaced by a MAC.
And there's no notion of
secret key and public key.
We have only one key.
And how do we verify?
OK, so verify function
basically just
becomes the other
guy also recomputes
the MAC of the
message and checks
whether that's the signature.
So verifier just to recompute
and compare correctness--
we also want correctness.
We also want unforgeability
And it's defined
in exactly the same way.
Now, actually, I would have
asked this question here--
is hash a valid MAC?
The answer is still no because
MAC is a public function
that everyone can
compute, and it's trivial
come up with a forgery.
So thank you for
asking that question.
But the hash is
actually very close.
How can we get a message
authentication code?
So several ideas.
Can we just hash the key
concatenated with the message?
Then some other random attacker
who doesn't have the key
does not know how to
compute this thing.
That's a reasonable idea.
But, well, if we can do it
this way, how about we do
the message concatenated
with the key.
Or if you want, you can do
key concatenated with message
and then concatenated
with the key.
So it turns out
this doesn't work
for some very advanced reasons.
And this one may or may not.
For SHA1, it doesn't
work, unfortunately.
And for SHA3-- that's the
replacement for SHA1 and SHA2--
it actually works.
So the simplest
MAC we can imagine
is just to choose SHA3
as the hash function,
and input is the key
and then the message.
Not the other way.
It's also, just FYI, purpose.
By the way, there's
another reasonable thought.
That is, how about
we encrypt the hash?
Now, everyone can
compute the hash,
but they don't know
how to encrypt.
If I use, say, a
secret key encryption,
this turns out to
be wrong as well.
That's digital signature in MAC.
But one caveat here,
our unforgeability
is defined this way.
A little bit strange,
but it makes sense.
But it indeed has some
weakness in some applications.
So imagine, say, I send you a
message-- today's recitation
is canceled.
And it has my signature on it.
So you can verify it
indeed comes from me.
But once I send that message,
every of you has that message.
So next week, one of you
can send that message again,
saying, today's
recitation is canceled.
Then you have no idea
whether it's indeed me
sending the message
again or someone
doing an April Fool's Day joke.
So how do we prevent that?
Well, of course,
one thing I can do
is if I'm smart I'll say,
today, like in parenthesis, May
the 8th, recitation is canceled.
Then you cannot
repeat that message.
But we want to protect
human stability.
That's the whole
point of cryptography.
So one thing we
could do, let's see.
Very simple modification.
When I sign the
message, I'll sign 1,
concatenated with my message.
Next time I sign 2,
And then 3, 4, and just
have this counter that
keeps incrementing.
It naturally fixes.
So you can verify if you
receive the same message
with the same
counter, then you know
it's someone else
who is resending it.
So that's one
thing we need to do
for signature in practical use.
Now, consider another totally
different application.
So say I think everyone
uses Google Drive,
Dropbox, something like that.
You store a bunch of files
on this cloud server.
Now you are here.
You'll have a, say, cell phone,
and you can access your files.
But how do you know
when you read a file,
it is indeed your
file unmodified?
How do, maybe Google
messes with you,
or there's someone in the
middle who changes your file?
Usually, most people
do not care about that,
while in cryptography,
we do care about that.
So in that case, MAC and
signatures do not help us.
Why?
Because if you just store
a MAC alongside each file,
what went wrong?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You need to
modify the MAC too.
PROFESSOR: But if
they modify the file,
they do not know how
to generate a MAC
for their version of the file.
But what they can do
is you have this file
and then you come and write
it, and you generate a new MAC.
When you read it, they
give you the old version.
That has the valid
signature or MAC on it
because you generated
that for it.
You all see the problem?
You haven't seen the problem?
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
they give you the old version?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
you have this file.
You generate a MAC, but
you-- at some point,
you want to update the file.
You want to update this
file to this file prime,
and generate a new MAC.
Maybe then file double
prime, MAC double prime.
In this application,
we want freshness.
When you read this file,
you want the latest version
of the file.
So it should be what you
wrote there last time.
But when you are trying
to read the file,
an attacker can
give you this pair.
If you check the MAC,
it's going to match.
This is also a valid
message MAC pair.
Now, everyone sees the problem.
OK, so what can we do?
Well, one thing we could do
is store all these MACs here
on your phone.
MAC1, MAC2-- a MAC
for every single file.
But if you do that, in fact,
we do not need MAC anymore.
We can just use hash.
So I'll say sigma-- I'll use
sigmas, but they mean hashes.
This is probably good
enough in practice.
I'll say these files
are x1, x2, x3, x4.
Now you just create a
hash for each of them
and store them locally.
And the model here is that an
attacker cannot modify files
on your own computer
or on your own phone.
And then you can
download the file.
Match-- compares it with the
latest version of the hash,
and then you're convinced
that it's the latest version.
This is probably a
good enough solution.
The only downside is that we do
have to store a lot of hashes
if you have a lot of files.
Or in our algorithmic
terminology,
we say your space
complexity is o of n.
Here, I mean your local space.
So can we somehow reduce
the local space complexity?
Well, one thing we could do is
to concatenate all the files
together, generate a single
hash, and store that one hash.
So hash everything in one try.
Then we do have o of 1 space,
but there's a bigger problem.
Can anyone tell me?
AUDIENCE: You don't know
which file to modify?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK,
I think you are
thinking in the right thing.
So how do I verify?
I cannot verify a single file.
I have to download all the files
and recompute a hash to verify.
So the time
complexity is o of n.
And, also, if I want
to update this file,
I have to recompute the hash.
That involves, again,
downloading all the files
and feed them into that hash.
And we do have a better solution
than both of them, which
is called a hash tree
or a Merkle tree,
which was invented by Merkle.
What we will do is so
first for every file,
we're going to create a hash.
Let me, again, use sigma
because h is unclear
whether it's a hash
value or a hash function.
Sigma 2, sigma 3, sigma 4.
So I said a hash tree.
And guess what's
the next step to do?
AUDIENCE: Cross the hashes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
We're going to create a sigma
5, which is the hash of sigma 1,
concatenated with sigma 2.
So we do the same thing here.
And so you all know
what it is, right?
I don't need to write it.
And keep going until
we got a root hash.
And now we're going to store
this thing locally on the side.
So what's the local
storage complexity?
o of 1-- we're only
storing one hash locally.
Now, what's the time complexity?
OK, so how do I verify?
Yeah.
Log in-- how do I verify?
I need to, so, first verify
if this hash matches,
and then read this
hash, and verify
whether this link matches,
and verify whether this one
matches, and then I'm done.
If I want to update, I also
need to update this hash,
then it causes
this hash to change
and then that hash to change.
But it's always some
path in that tree.
It doesn't affect
anything globally.
Question.
AUDIENCE: But you're not
storing like sigma 5?
PROFESSOR: Say again.
AUDIENCE: You're
not storing sigma 5.
PROFESSOR: I am not.
I have to go ahead and read it.
AUDIENCE: From where?
PROFESSOR: From Google
Drive or Dropbox.
AUDIENCE: So are we sure
that that is secure?
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah, so
that's the next thing
we're going to do.
Is this secure?
Or in other words,
can the adversary
change one of the
files, and somehow
maintain the same root hash?
That's your question then.
Of course, we assume the
hash is collision resistant.
Or I should say if the hash
is collision resistant,
then this hash tree is
collision resistant.
Any intuition?
Or anyone wants to prove it?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So like if the root
eventually one of the leaves
will be different
because it changes.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Now, you want
the root to be the same
than the other hash
has to be different,
but there's no collisions.
I mean, it's hard to
find the other hash.
PROFESSOR: Correct, so I'll
just repeat what you said,
but I'll start with the leaf
because that's easier for me
to think about.
So say I change this
one, this block.
Now, I claim this
hash here will change.
If it doesn't, then I
have found the collision.
Because this x4 prime has the
same hash as the original x4.
So if this sigma 4 changes,
then sigma 6 will change.
Otherwise, I have
found the collision.
Because this sigma 3
concatenate with the new sigma
4 is my collision.
So same argument-- either
this one changes, or I
have found the collision.
I repeat the argument
all the way to the root.
Any question about that?
AUDIENCE: What if like the
adversary changes like two hash
options--for
example, x1 and x2--
but sigma 1 and sigma 2 changes,
but sigma 5 stays the same?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
then we have found
the collision that is sigma
1 concatenated with sigma 2.
That's a collision with the
new sigma 1 concatenated
with the new sigma 2.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: If the concatenation
stayed the same, like sigma 1
and sigma 2 concatenation.
PROFESSOR: So if the
concatenation stayed the same,
that means both of
them are the same.
AUDIENCE: They had to make
sure they are changed?
PROFESSOR: So I'm not sure
I understand your question.
So concatenation is
basically just a bunch
of bits then followed by
another bunch of bits.
If this entire
thing is the same,
that means this part is the
same and this part is the same.
And if your sigma 1, new sigma
1 is the same as your old sigma
1, that means I have
found a collision here.
Because we changed it, but
your sigma doesn't change.
So lastly, I'm going to do a
quick review of the knapsack
problem because I think in the
lecture, we may run out of time
and I didn't mention everything.
So if you recall, the
knapsack cryptosystem,
it says you have a
knapsack problem.
I'll call u1 to un.
And then we're going
to transform it.
OK, this is a super
increasing sequence.
I'm going to transform into a
general one by multiplying n
and then mod m.
So this is an easy problem,
and that is a hard problem.
So how do I encrypt?
I'm going to take a subset
sum, which is mi, Wi, where mi
is the i-th bit in the message.
So how do I decrypt?
I'll take this, transform this
s back to the super increasing
domain by multiplying
inverse of n.
So that's going to be inverse
of n multiplied by this mi Wi.
That's how I encrypt it.
And then each Wi is n times ui.
So far so good.
So that gives me
mi times ui sigma.
Of course, every
step is modulo m.
So the first thing
I'm going to claim
is that m has to be
larger than sigma ui.
If that's the case, then the t--
my t is just this subset sum.
So if I solve this
knapsack problem,
I get the same answer
as solving the original,
the general knapsack problem.
If my m is not that large,
if the m is too small,
then I have a problem.
Because then my t
will be the subset sum
minus sum multiple of m.
Then it's a different problem.
I do not get the
same message back.
OK, then we have a problem.
So because we defined density
to be n over the log of max ui.
Does everyone
remember this part?
So each ui is in the range
of 1 to m, or maybe 0 to m.
If I have a bunch of them, then
this is not super rigorous.
If I have a bunch of them,
chances are that some of them
are very close to m.
Because it's unlikely that
all of them are small.
So this thing is
roughly n over log of m.
So then we have a dilemma.
If we set m to be
a small number,
then my density
is fine, but that
means all of my ui's
needs to be small
because m needs to be
greater than the sum of them.
If all the ui's
are small, then I
have a very limited
choices of them,
then actually an
attacker can just
guess what ui I chose by a brute
force algorithm or something
like that.
And if I choose m
to be large, or if I
choose all the ui's to
be large, to choose them
from large range, then my m
is going to be very large.
And this density is low.
And that's vulnerable to
the low density attacks.
And so how low a density
is considered low?
So several people proposed
that based on heuristics,
that if this density
is less than 0.45,
then it's considered
low density,
and it can be attacked.
And this threshold
had been improved.
So but while most of the
knapsack cryptosystems
are broken, there
are few that have
so far stood the test of time.
So they are still interesting
because knapsack problems,
knapsack cryptosystems will
be much faster than RSA
or any number theory
based, because we are just
adding numbers here.
An RSA have this operation
where m is a 1,000 bit number,
and e is also 1,000 bit number.
And take this exponentiation
is actually very slow.
So knapsack cryptosystem
are still interesting.
However, the original motivation
turned out to be unsuccessful.
The original motivation
is to base cryptography
on the NP complete problem.
That's not going to work because
NP problems are hard, only
in the worst case.
And we need cryptography to
be hard in the average case.
Because if they are only
hard in the worst case,
that means there are
several instances
of this problem that are hard.
So either you pick
a secret key that
doesn't correspond
to a hard problem,
or you pick a secret key that's
corresponds to a hard problem.
But everyone else picks
the same secret key
because everyone
wants to be secure.
That's the reason why it's
unlikely to get cryptography
from NP hard problems.
That's all for
today's recitation.
And thanks everyone for
the entire semester.
Thank you for participation.